bien on va faire une petite un thème
c'est qu'on bouge pas pendant le jingle
vous le savez ça à pierre
il bouge ne manquent pas moi je peux pas
m'empêcher de sourire en regardant lui
bouge même mon pack à vous êtes joueur
bien alors l'interview nul donc chez les
questions les plus cons possible et les
réponses et plus conne possible on va
voir est-ce que ça c'est la question la
première question c'est la question qui
nous a été donnée par clotilde courau
qui désormais est une amie sa lutte le
tilt est-ce que par amour vous embrasse
riez cent fois de suite des chaussettes
sales
jeunes amour oui par amaury vide va
écouter malgré tout l'amour que je
pourrais avoir pour une dame je ne
supporterais pas qu'elle soit salle donc
je ne pourrais pas embrasser nos pc
josette ça et vous vous le feriez marion
non je déconne il accueille aussi j'ai
peur quelques côtes il de kuroky fasse
ce genre de truc je pourrais le faire
s'il a le propriétaire des chaussettes
est parti depuis très longtemps à voilà
qu assez beau cette richesse du fait de
chirurgie vous posez la question c'est
un peu mes t shirts
amer j'ai posé toutes les questions sur
le fétiche ou est-ce que vous préfériez
votre père ou votre mère
je vais vous dire très sincèrement ce
propos tellement con comme question 16
ans est très content mais je suis
incapable de répondre si si je vais pas
me répond si si si il se trouve que ma
mère a été j'avais cinq ans quand elle
est tombée malade et donc j'ai toujours
vu une personne aux lits acquis à la fin
je faisais ces piqûre de morphine ouais
donc c'est vrai que la personne vivante
avec moi celui qui m'a vraiment éduquer
c'est mon père ouais et donc finalement
je pourrais dire que j'aimais plus mon
père que ma mère même si ça paraît comme
ça parce que c'était une personne
vivante alors que j'avais en face de moi
gamin une personne uniquement malades
qui était ma maman est ce que vous
préférez hitler ou staline
alors il ya un grand débat vous savez
que li na qui se dit pas tomber si on
préfère en général dire qu'on préfère
staline parce que l'idée communiste way
est une idée généreuse alors clean et la
sinn les papes c'est ce qu'on dit c'est
ce qu'on dit moi personnellement je
trouve ce sont deux monstres absolument
à rigaud
il ya aucune différence quoi selon les
aveux c'est vraiment laissé des frères
jumeaux mais ma préférence à vraiment
hitler ou staline moi je déteste plus
hitler parce qu'effectivement il cette
idée d' éradiquer de la surface de la
terre des gens parce qu'ils sont d'une
religion d'une origine les juifs les
tziganes ou les homosexuels mais staline
on peut lui en vouloir peut-être autant
parce qu'il a trahi une belle idée ouais
il aurait tué quand même eu à tuer cent
mille
est-ce que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en christophe dechavanne
nagui ou arthur
écoutez je pense de lui quelques
difficultés actuelles moi donc je tiens
absolument à murray me réincarner en à
guy wilks voilà assez gentil ces
chrétiens parce que c'est parce que
c'est mon producteur oui
je sais que c'est le meilleur coach que
j'ai eu la garde côte d'où sont repartis
avec des bêtises monsieur pierre je
n'avais pas assez de prime time depuis
86 ouais bon donc il me fallait
quelqu'un qui meurent et après une zone
la pêche comment un email is back time
et ça a été un coach absolument
extraordinaire donc c'est bien le dire
en tous les cas chez moi j'aimerais bien
tagi quel est votre punition préférez
vous préférez être passé mort du piquet
ou griffer
mordu mort du pain c'est piqué ou griffé
à la morsure dans l'amour ça existe oh
il est choqué raw
mais c'est un qui va le plus mal qu'un
su son volume normal et pourtant c'est
tentant
est-ce que vous préféreriez pendant dix
ans c'est une vue de l'esprit bien sûr
pas de sexe ou pas mangé
pendant dix ans elle en disant pas de
sexe pas manger
c'est une façon de me demander si je
préférais baiser ou bouffer en gros
ben je pense quand même que pour partir
sur dix ans comme ava creux on va
forcément crever si revanche pas il faut
quand même choisir de ne pas se taper
quiconque le problème est d'accord mais
si vous êtes tout seul et change devient
un théâtre robinson crusoé toi c'est
insupportable et enfin vendredi arriver
là quand même enceinte
vous n'êtes pas d'accord
alors bon et vous préféreriez être
aveugle et sourd ou amputé des bras et
des jambes non non c'est vrai des
cotonnades etc et sur la course
aveugle et sourd ou alors en plus tôt
firmin mahé bas au fond c'est quand même
amputé des bras et des jambes parce que
aveugle et sourd c'est quelque chose que
je dis
vous portez un script un caleçon en rien
un slip c'est très important
on se demande dès fois à quoi social
services publics la honte voilà je vous
donne également les mâles même marqué
suisse marc quel animal qui embrasse le
mieux l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
j'ai horreur de me faire embarrassé par
les aliments à bordeaux cazaux du tout
je ne remet pas du tout assez marrant
c'est un peu comme marion cotillard
alors j'adore j'adore me faire passer
par qui on voudra mais pas parisien bon
la dernière question pierre bellemare
comment vendriez vous un vibromasseur
qui se recharge sur l'allume-cigare
je commencerai par dire
cheikh ali oui l'objet que je vais
vendre doit absolument être utilisée sur
un parking et en aucun cas pendant la
marche du bic
à partir du moment où vous avez branché
en liga le vibromasseur que je vais vous
proposer
tout est possible le nirvana peut
arriver et donc il est impossible de
jouir de nirvana cyr en même temps est
en train de doubler nos deux seuls 2 h
sur l'eau bravo restaurer
et
fillon
qui avait lui aussi joué dans un pays
violent